oh hi if you're one of those early
adopters who purchased a nintendo 3ds
back when it was 250 and then
immediately saw the price drop get ready
to get your wallets out again because as
of august 19th your new portable system
is obsolete old and busted out like a
pair of leg warmers that's right meet
the nintendo 3ds xl the most obvious
improvement here is that the screens are
about twice as big as the original 3ds
but there's actually a lot of other
smaller tweaks that are not as
immediately apparent here is the full
rundown games on 3ds xl look better than
ever thanks to the massive 3d screen but
if you don't like 3d for any reason like
if you have a lazy eye or if stereoscopy
killed your family now you can click it
off and the slider won't come back up
unless you definitely want it to
speaking of clicks the buttons below the
screen are now actual buttons instead of
horrible membrane things that barely
work you have to push really hard on
that's that's done
finally the stylus pen is now in a much
more convenient position it's stored on
the side of the 3ds xl not all the way
over on the top
3ds games look great and regular ds
games look better too thanks to the
extra screen size they look a little
blurry when they're blown up full screen
but here's the trick if you hold down
the start button when you boot them it
shows them in a one to one pixel ratio
this leaves a big black border around
the screen but it looks a lot clearer
the same goes for the black and white
downloadable game boy games that you can
get off of the 3ds's eshop they look
very blurry when they're blown up in
normal mode but again hold down start
and boot them up and it makes the pixel
ratio one to one and gives you this
really neat border image it's like you
never threw away your game boy
now speaking of downloads the first
thing you should do when you get your
3ds xl is transfer all of your data over
from your original 3ds all of your spot
pass and street pass data and saved
games and downloaded games and all of
that use the system transfer option
first because when you use the system
transfer it actually deletes all of the
data from your old system and it deletes
any data that's already on your new
system this is not like the iphone or
the ipad where you just buy a new device
log into your account and redownload
your stuff it does not work that way it
has to take the data off one system and
move it to another so if you plan on
using your 3ds xl all the time and i
guarantee that you will considering how
nice this thing is you're going to want
to make sure you transfer all of your
data first thing you do
one of the best parts about the 3ds xl's
larger form factor is that it has a
bigger battery and thus better battery
life i have found myself having to
recharge the 3ds xl much less than i did
with my 3ds which as you know if you
have one you're constantly running out
of battery going back to recharge it 3ds
xl it seems like it holds a charge
better holds more charge it's a lot
better in the battery department
and coming in at about 200 it's actually
way cheaper than the original launch
price of the 3ds so if you do a lot of
3ds gaming yes you're definitely going
to want to upgrade to the 3ds xl when it
comes out in america on august 19th
you